[Music]
in dying tradition news submitted by me
master 19 19 19 19 19 a bathhouse in
Japan is offering naked school to lure
bathers in parlor go so far and the hell
is going on it is unisex uh naked school
or is it just boy stay on this side girl
stay on that side and what kind of
school what are we gonna be learning
this is small isn't small what are we
gonna be learning I'm confused because
when I write here school I hear no way I
don't want to go there plus like when
you're in a and I like long sense are
you gonna pay attention this should
relax this [ __ ] you got somebody
scrubbing your back or whatever like all
the gangsters and load the beneath
dancers behind you scrubbing it back so
this bathhouse in Tokyo it's called
Hinode you fat hell mm-hmm and so what
they're doing is that they're recently
offering this naked school to entice
younger bathers to come and bathe
because they're saying that now like the
tradition is kind of dying because
everyone has bats in their own home so
they don't have to go to a communal bath
anymore you okay
like I should just say it has some more
ticket I remember
remember only for the two old men
washing each other a long time ago at
the Bally finger oh yeah oh we embarked
it and then like this guy's like he's
like this he's in this position in his
homies just cooking cookies when you go
to like a gym they have the shower stall
and then there's a handicap shower stall
so it's way better right but for some
reason they didn't close the door so
it's a naked guy on the [ __ ]
handicapping
and the other guy going like this to
look like Asian guy the original course
this is Tunisian dressing is that in
that gym is my half asian half Mexicans
and I'm like why do those are people
always have to make us look so bad
you see all those older Mexican guys
watching like what the [ __ ] is going on
with the guy scrubbing was he like
directly behind or was he off to the
side scrubbing directly be hi I'm sure
they were like this it was like like one
guys holding on to dear life like this
and then the other guys [ __ ]
scrubbing like all the way up to his
back of his neck all the way down to his
butt cheek like like it was a job that I
got contracted to do and no one else is
in the world right now that's what it
was that's the older gangster younger K
and then you have the [ __ ] cholos
like the old veteranos walking by like
what the [ __ ] is this
yeah we're just watching like I mean
this will be cool in like a ginger bond
or some kind of Asian spa but 24 hours a
week idea supposed to the world
I hope please like come on do I have an
explanation this is a Claudia tradition
yeah hey in Asia it's okay to scrub your
brother hey hey hey this is a bath house
yeah so what the Nagus pool means is
that you know like a topic every month
and so for example they had one topic
where was comedy and they were teaching
comedy I'm not sure exactly how I don't
think they were teaching comedy at the
bath house and like another topic is um
hey what did the chicken why did the
chicken cross the road
I can eat plenty toss take a hey
everybody welcome to the bass school
today we're gonna teach a Joe I just
don't know how you could teach anybody
such a relaxing environment
so Asian they're attracting people to
come in with schooling
it's not free food or like here's a
chance to win a car or whatever it's
like here's more his homework well they
said like they know that this is really
odd so like that's why they wanted
something so out there to really like
bring attention to the side it does make
me curious so like it does make me go
well I want to learn stand-up comedy she
said walk naked yoga
they should be normal like Vegas you
know like the casinos that are dying in
front of the tables there's like some
hot girl dancing so like and those are
the casino strategy I just bring a hot
girl have her dance I can't do that
because it's not a family environment
anymore yeah they're trying to make it
back to the tradition of like the CentOS
then just have bomb free food
well what can we just be eating I don't
know
well you're in the jacuzzi have you guys
try eating while you might be in a
bathtub no ice cream it's delicious no
it's not very nice you never I scream in
the bathroom no like a hot tub I'm sorry
hustle yeah hot and hot tub we gotta get
a Hut that's [ __ ] funny yes I would
imagine it to be gross because if you
like drop stuff in there it's just like
a little like being in a hot soup while
I'm eating food hot soup why you're in a
soup and you eat this we have that in
Japan it's gross yeah tell ramen I like
to exist but yeah what is your like huge
cup of noodle yeah and then you eat yeah
you eat I know I don't know about that
that's kind of
well you better scrub your body down to
the mag no matter how much Olga very
little flavor comes from when the
[ __ ] hair in the hair I would
purposes not shower to add more flavour
to the block okay so you have my [ __ ]
I'm not going after bartha's I know
that's weird
you guys are now some nasty as bland
ramen and my mom's gonna be delicious
that is dressed up and put in that even
have the beer I think I'll do but you
don't really drink the beer like one
that one five something in Germany yeah
but I want to do that thing where they
take that super super hot bath and they
jump into the cold a flake [ __ ] I
think I'm ready
non-dualistic on respawn yeah we stop
talking about like this is ice water and
this pretty it's pretty cold are we spot
yeah it's really hot and really cold
what is that supposed to do it's also
good for you right your muscle for your
red blood cell
oh you lighting right now you just show
you for real mm-hmm
you just say things had enough yes
anyways this bath house has been open
since 1939 and it's been family ran this
whole time and so they're saying that
added like in its heyday they'd be more
than 500 people that would go there
every single day but now it's down to
like about a hundred good so they're
trying to you know make it more exciting
again for people to come and visit it
they say that they charge the admission
price of four US dollars or forty four
hundred and sixteen back yet that's hell
is a cheap four bucks why the [ __ ] not
yeah and then H each month the topic of
the naked school changes so then like
another topic is how they're telling you
the entire history of the bath industry
is all telling us how museum yeah so
much now yeah I mean there's like I want
to go to the study I want to go to
relaxer you know we went to a hot
springs arkansas over the holidays and
it was pretty cool because they have
like an entire street or it's like
forgot what they call it with like
bathroom or something like the entire
rooms it's all bath houses houses and
then some of them are museums and then
Toni like the history of it it's pretty
crazy how is that one different than
like we spa
do they have like food and entertainment
oh it's such because that data we were
there we wanted to experience it but
then it was like fully booked and so we
saw there was like three bad houses that
we went to in each one it was fully
booked so within you go full moon I
don't know I didn't get to experience it
oh you know what's interesting I wonder
I want I really do want to know the
difference between American
spa and then Asian spa because does it
do it I've done dimensional in your
fluid level Glenn idealize I hated it
because I know like I like Asian karaoke
versus American karaoke is quite
different like Asian cavity of your own
room it's personal you just do whatever
your life people you have to be inside a
bar while everybody
watching you yeah yeah which I don't
like I like doing it with amongst my
friends a mic opened and it's fun a
little like little Lightroom my joke
then you could change the octave the key
yourself and then on top of that you
have service people come through with
like you can get like a tray of fruits
some so did you get drunk throw up in
there have the people clean it up oh
that sounds fun
I have you heard this place offering
naked school what do you guys think
there actually I just get horny oh do
you think they're teaching them I is I
like I said like I just feel like sounds
like a porn like a beginning of a porno
to me everybody's naked in the bath tub
together sexy schoolgirls all around me
[ __ ] teacher starts boning the
students building a family environment I
never happened yet I know but like my
fantasy gets in the way of reality
sometimes there is way better than mine
because mine I picture a bunch of naked
people in the desk
oh good you're learning and they just
just naked and then school's out and
then they go they have their backpacks
I hope you all hard to pay attention if
you're like just in a single bath by
yourself and then your teacher with a
female is just naked like reading stuff
to you probably like 60 or 70 gone that
in my head to not make you throw up the
size like 28 years old
you know there's um like hot springs off
the road on the way to the Las Vegas or
mmhmm yeah it's like a secret place and
I always wanted to check it out you sure
yeah because like I like nature for one
and two I like to go to places where not
a lot of people are there and get naked
I just an adventurer [ __ ] - I like that
because it makes me feel like hey what
happened is what time is it I don't know
is it 17 33 and I'm now monkey I don't
know you a monkey
you better not be missing no just
kidding news
loads so go down and subscribe for our
channel so you can see more video okay
and there's another one up here check it
out
[Music]